Jerry Jones is a happy man today oh yes
he is
give me some Johnnie Walker Blue and
take me for a ride on the bus shoes are
optional today because he's gotten his
deal done Ezekiel Elliott six-year 90
million dollar extension signed for
eight seasons they've got four of their
five offensive linemen locked up through
2023
they've got Jaylon Smith under contract
to Marcus Lawrence is under contract
everybody except that Prescott Amari
Cooper they're gonna have to deal with
that little predicament next but when
you look at it right everyone is there
now Jaylon Smith was the first big
domino to fall but now that we have the
offensive guys in place you've got zq
elliot dak Prescott Amari Cooper it is
is this the best Cowboys team that we've
seen since the days of Aikman and Ervin
and Emmitt I mean it's really close now
I think some of those like 2007 teams
were pretty damn good too you know with
Terrell Owens and Tony Romo where I
would say that's like neck-and-neck to
me but what did they ever do yeah I know
they didn't do anything you're right I
just say that but they were still number
one seed in the playoffs I didn't
believe one year when they lost the
Giants for the trip to Mexico right that
whole thing so I mean those were
talented two teams certainly I think
this team when I look at as a whole I
probably go it's a little more talent to
the name and those teams I think it is
the best team since the early 90s yes I
mean once they're really do ask question
about the roster right I only have one
question about the football team in
general and you tell me if you agree
with me or not it's really one phase the
passing offense it's the only thing I
question right I mean last year they
were 23rd passing offense in football
and I know there are a run first
football team but I just worry about
that aspect of their game if Zeke's
getting stuffed by a good defense in a
certain week against some quality
playoff type of teams can they overcome
that consistently and go oh no our
passing game is pretty elite we can we
can rely on that too they've had such a
basic matchup driven off yes where
everybody's in the same place all the
time there's no creativity there's no
pre snap motion there's no funky
formations it's all about having the
bigger stronger faster guys and letting
them go be bigger stronger and faster
and this year
is the first conscious transition away
from that we'll see how it goes as you
point out all the time kellen more the
new offensive coordinator who looks like
he's younger than my 15 year old nephew
frankly but he is a guy who learned
offense from the guy they fired yes I
got it right I gotta know with the other
the other you know area of inventory he
has in his offense I mean really other
than you know let's see was it was he he
was at Boise State okay then he comes to
Detroit he gets a year rajole Lombardi
other than that that's the only other
NFL thoughts or schematics he's had put
in his brain other than Scott Linehan so
I do I got to see what they're going to
do what he's gonna do how he's gonna
kind of kind of reinvent this offense
with all the issues you talked about it
is very stagnant it's the same
formations over and over and over and as
we saw in like the pile off game they
couldn't run the ball what was it the
passing offense wasn't pretty
it was dak Prescott making plays he just
had to make plays and be like oh I got a
scramble to make throws on the run and
when you know and then on defense
they're a little the same way they're
kind of like hey this is what we do deal
with it we're bigger and faster like
you're saying we're gonna beat you up oh
well the Rams and Shawn McVeigh cracked
the code and they found out a few things
you were doing under defensive front
where you got out schemed and it didn't
matter if you were the bigger faster
team it didn't matter so those are just
the little issues I worry about with the
Dallas Cowboys just getting them over
the hump as far as they want to get out
of the divisional round and get to a
championship game or a Super Bowl and
you know what no excuses for Jason
Garrett now who's in the last year of
his contract is the head coach of the
team if it doesn't work out no buyout no
problem right see you later and you
bring someone in and you should be able
to attract anyone you want with that
roster especially if and when they get
back Prescott in the contract assuming
that the next coach would would say dak
Prescott is my guy and I think that any
coach should say dak Prescott my guy can
find a way to make it work with him I
think the guy is far better than he gets
credit for and that puts more pressure
on Jason Garrett a rocky ride for him in
Dallas he has survived in large part
because he allows Jerry Jones to be the
one who sucks all the oxygen out of the
room sure he's not that typical I'm the
coach go sit down and shut up like
Parcells was like Jimmie Johnson was not
so he let's Jerry be Jerry and he
doesn't need to have that notoriety but
at the same time he hasn't gotten the
results that you would look to and say
this guy is one of the better coaches in
the NFL he's squarely middle with a pack
that best it's been up and down I mean
they've you know traditionally like
you've talked about many times have been
going to the playoffs fall off go to the
playoffs fall off now I will say I think
this is a year
I mean I'm picking them to to go to the
playoffs I'll let that out of the bag
right now even though I have learned now
we're gonna do that a little a little
later on in the show but I do think this
is the most complete roster he's had and
there's you know no Tony Romo back
injury to worry about where then all of
a sudden Calvin Moore has to play some
quarterback and do things like that I
don't see a weakness to their roster I
think they are a very good football team
I'm glad Jerry Jones got Ezekiel Elliott
in there because you'd you don't want to
early season cheap loss hanging over
your head because Zeke wasn't there and
the passing game couldn't pick up the
slack for the lack of a running game at
all of that but they've done a good job
of orchestrating their roster man they
got waves at defensive linemen you know
you mentioned the offensive linemen are
signed up for years and years
Ziqi Elliott's there for years and years
now and they got a good base to be very
competitive in the NSC for a while yeah
they did that layout Collins deal
yesterday and it's a heck of a team
friendly deal heck I mean it's it makes
it easier to keep some of these guys
yeah all right
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports